since we are talking about delivering
the truth I'm gonna actually jump into
this little section right here which is
called tactfully delivering the truth
when delivering criticism it is
important to do it with consideration
and delicacy if you punch someone in the
face with criticism they will become
defensive and are unlikely to take the
criticism on board so a more indirect
approach is needed and again that's what
we just talked about with the other
section which is oh look I'm just going
to tell them what's up you need to
control your ego you know that's gonna
work out great okay so how do we do this
how do we tell the truth tactfully okay
here first care about your people that's
number one care about your people if you
truly care about them they will know
that and they will accept your criticism
more easily and this is this is
something that I fought about talking
with Flynn and when I was the OIC of
trade at I was actually listening to
Flynn at the muster and he was talking
about these savage debriefs that I would
give and I have some recorded all
playing for you sometimes oh they're
savage yeah I was coming off the top
ropes I mean I was coming off the top
ropes and as I'm sitting there listening
it to Flint because even at that time
like Flynn Cochrane not hard guy to read
right like like he's he's not a guy
that's like hey I'm not sure what he's
thinking like you know you're looking at
Flynn you're like okay I see where he's
at Lafe same thing right
Lafe is like hey you know what is that
what is that term where's where your
motion on your sleeves right Lafe is no
stranger life is not shy about saying
hey i'm not exactly good and he's I mean
imagine you know at least in it like now
but imagine when life was or whatever
right not exactly able to contain his
emotions or hide his emotions so as I'm
listening to Flynn up there talking
about how I used to give these savage
briefs and Cirelli same thing right like
how hard is it to tell when sir Elly's
pissed off it's like so easy right so
when I'm sitting there listening Syme
thinking man I used to debrief these guy
not all those guys every one of them I
gave them debriefs
that were born full right and I'm
thinking myself what how is it that on
any of their faces any of their faces I
never saw that look of like screw you
you know what shut up you don't know
what you're talking about never and and
I real and it was the same with like I
had one guy that had that that I could
read that on that I put through training
and he's the guy that in podcast number
five I wrote a counseling letter for
which I very seldom did and explained to
him that he was not gonna make it in the
SEAL Teams if he didn't be moral if he
wasn't didn't become more humble and a
bunch of other things but that's a guy
that I could I could see on his face
like when I was debriefing him he was
pissed but every now think I mean I'd
debriefs hundreds of guys and and yet
they would always be like like Roger you
know like that kind of like they
disappointed me like it wasn't they were
disappointed that that's the that's the
feeling I always got from Flynn was I
can you know Roger or from life like
Roger you know like that's what I that's
what I always got back why is that it's
real easy the reason is because all
those guys knew and and the guys that I
was putting through training knew more
than anything else in the world I cared
about them and I knew that they were
going overseas and I knew that they're
going into combat and more than anything
else I wanted them to be able to
accomplish the mission and I wanted them
and their guys to be safe and okay and
come home and they knew that so when it
comes to delivering truthful feedback
the number one thing is to care about
your people number one and then the next
thing is take ownership of your problem
of the problem itself of course extreme
ownership should be the fundamental
principle used utilized by any leader
and
our tactics of employing extreme
ownership when trying to critique a
subordinate you utilizing extreme
ownership while providing feedback might
sound like this here's some tactical
maneuvers instead of saying you failed
to get the project done on time use what
support or assets could I have given you
so that we could have gotten the project
done on time instead of saying you
failed to meet the mission objectives
try using I don't think I did a good job
of explaining the mission objective did
you fully understand it
instead of saying your lack of
professionalism caused this client to go
to our competitor try saying I think I
allowed things to get too slack around
here in terms of our professionalism I
think that's one of the reasons why we
lost that client to one of our
competitors
now there's guaranteed to be people
listening this right now that are
thinking what would you that's weak you
should just tell them how are they ever
gonna understand what you're talking
about and it goes back to this when I
attack them they're not listening that's
all there is to it when I attack them
the whole thing now if you have a great
relationship with you if they know you
care about them if you know that if they
know that you have their best their best
interests and that's why you're talking
to him yeah you can you can go harder
and also when you get people that you
try indirect approaches on and it fails
well then you escalate your directness
and over time until you're eventually
like listen you failed this project and
this is not acceptable and if it happens
like yes you get there totally
absolutely don't start there don't start
there and by the way also this is in the
book it's important to take note that
these are not simply techniques you are
utilizing so your pesky subordinate
falls into line that is not the point
the point of all these statements and
the whole point of taking ownership is
that you must truly believe what you are
saying and you should because the
ownership statements and those examples
are not simply lip-service they are true
if the leader follows up with the team
members and make sure that they have all
the support and assets they needed to
complete the job on time then the job
will get done on time if a leader
correctly explains the mission in simple
clear concise manner and then ensures it
is understood by the team
the team will accomplish the mission if
a leader fails to emphasize the
importance of professionalism then it
should come as no surprise that
subordinates fail to act professionally
yes it's on you the leader